there were several significant
developments in the last few days linked
to gbt4 and openai I could honestly have
done a video on each of them but
realized that it might be better to do a
single video tracing a single article
covering seven major points I'm gonna
use this fascinating piece from the Ft
which millions of people have now read
to run you through what has happened
including Sam Altman's Revelation on
Gypsy 5. Elon musk's new AI company and
gpt4 conducting science the author by
the way is an investor in anthropic and
a co-author of the state of AI annual
report and he puts it like this a
three-letter acronym doesn't capture the
enormity of what AGI would represent so
I will refer to it as what it is Godlike
AI this would be a super intelligent
computer that learns and develops
autonomously that understands its
environment without the need for
supervision and that can transform the
world around it and the author Ian Hogan
says we are not there yet but the nature
of the technology makes it exceptionally
difficult to predict exactly when we
will get there the article presents this
as a diagram with the exponential curve
going up towards AGI and a much less
impressive curve on the progress on
alignment which he describes as a lining
AI systems with human values now I know
what some of you may be thinking surely
those at the top of openai disagree on
this gap between capabilities and
Alignment well first here is yarn Leica
who is the alignment team lead at openai
what does he think he wants everyone to
be reminded that aligning smarter than
human AI systems with human values is an
open research problem which basically
means it's unsolved but what about those
at the very top of open AI like Sam
Altman when he was drafting his recent
statement on the path to AGI he sent it
to Nate Suarez of the machine
intelligence Research Institute for one
of the paragraphs Nate wrote this I
think think that if we do keep running
ahead with the current capabilities to
alignment Ratio or even a slightly
better one we die after this Sam Altman
actually adjusted the statement adding
that said it's important that the ratio
of safety progress to capability
progress increases going back to the
article the author makes the point that
there are not that many people directly
employed in this area of alignment
across the core AGI labs and what
happened to that pause the experiment
letter that I did a video on well as
Hogarth points out the letter itself
became a controversy so many people in
my comments wrote that the only reason
certain people are signing this is the
slow open AI down so that they can catch
up and this cynicism unfortunately has
some new evidence that it can cite with
musk forming his new AI company called
xai this was reported 48 hours ago in
the Wall Street Journal but people have
seen this coming for months now
apparently the company has recruited
eagle babushkin from deepmind but has
not been that successful at recruiting
people from openai and I do have one
Theory as to why again according to the
Wall Street Journal when musk left open
AI in February of 2018. he explained
that he thought he had a better chance
of creating AGI through Tesla where he
had access to Greater resources when he
announced his departure a young
researcher at openai questioned whether
Mr musk had thought through the safety
implications according to their
reporting he then got frustrated and
insulted that in turn since then he's
also paused openai's access to Twitter's
database for training its new models so
it could be that Gypsy 5 isn't quite as
good at tweeting as gpt4 a few days ago
Sam Altman responded to the letter and
also broke news about gbt5 apologies for
the quality this was a private event and
this was the only footage available
um but unfortunately I think the letter
is missing like most technical nuance
about where we need to pause like an
earlier version of the letter claims
open a nice training gp5 right now we
are not normal for some time
um so in that sense it was sort of silly
but we are doing other things on top of
gpt4 that I think have all sorts of
safety issues that are important to
address and we're totally left out of
the letter it is impossible to know how
much this delay in the training of GT5
is motivated by safety concerns or by
merely setting up the requisite compute
for example the article quotes again
yarn Leica the head of alignment at open
AI he recently tweeted before we
scramble to deeply integrate llms
everywhere in the economy like Gypsy 4.
can we pause and think whether it is
wise to do so this is quite immature
technology and we don't understand how
it works if we're not careful we're
setting ourselves up for a lot of
correlated failures this is the head of
alignment at open AI but this was just
days before open AI then announced it
had connected gpt4 to a massive range of
tools including Slack and zapier so at
this point we can only speculate as to
what's going on at the top of open AI
meanwhile compute and emerging
capabilities are Marching on as the
author puts it these large AI systems
are quite different we don't really
program them we grow them and as they
grow their capabilities jump sharply you
add 10 times more compute or data and
suddenly the system behaves very
differently we also have this epic graph
charting the exponential Rising compute
of the latest language models if you
remember when Bard was launched it was
powered by Lambda well apparently now
Google's Bard is powered by harm which
has eight times as much computing power
that sounds impressive until you see
from the graph that the estimate for the
computing power inside gpt4 is 10 times
more again and remember this is not a
linear graph this is a log scale there
is a hundred times multiple between each
of the lines and what abilities emerge
at this scale here here is a slide from
Jason way who now works at open AI
formerly of Google this is from just a
few days ago and he says emergent
abilities are abilities that are not
present in small models but are present
in large models he says that there are a
lot of emergent abilities and I'm going
to show you a table from this paper in a
moment but he has four profound
observations of emergence one that it's
unpredictable emergence cannot be
predicted by extrapolating scaling
curves from smaller models two that they
are unintentional and that emergent
abilities are not explicitly specified
by the trainer of the model third and
very interestingly since we haven't
tested all possible tasks we don't know
the full range of abilities that have
emerged and of course that fourth
further scaling can be expected to
elicit more emergent abilities and he
asks the question any undesirable
emergent abilities question mark there
will be a link to the paper in the
description because there's no way I'll
be able to get through all of it but
here is a table showing some of the
abilities that emerge when you reach a
certain amount of compute power or
parameters things like Chain of Thought
reasoning you can't do that with all
models that's an ability that emerged
after a certain scale same thing with
following instructions and doing
addition and subtraction and how about
this for another emerging capacity the
ability to do autonomous scientific
research this paper shows how Gypsy 4
can design plan and execute scientific
experiments this paper was released on
the same day four days ago and it
followed a very similar design the model
in the center Gypsy 4 thinks out reasons
and plans and then interacts with real
tools when the authors say that they
were inspired by successful applications
in other fields I looked at the appendix
and they were talking about hugging GPT
I've done a video on that but it's a
similar design with the brain in the
center gpt4 deciding which tools to use
and let me just give you a glimpse of
what happens when you do this if you
look at this chart on the top left you
can see how gpt4 on its own performs in
yellow and then in purple you can see
how Gypsy 4 performs when you hook it up
to other tools I'll show you some of the
tasks in a moment but look at the
dramatic increase in performance the
human evaluators gave GT4 when it had
tools a perfect score on seven of the
tasks these were things like proposing
similar novel non-toxic molecules but
the model could be abused to propose the
synthesis of chemical weapons and gpt4
only refused to continue after it had
calculated all the required quantities
and the authors conclude that guard
rails must be put in place on this
emerging capability I think this diagram
from Max tegmark's life 3.0 shows the
landscape of capabilities that AI has
and might soon have as you can see
science and art were thought to be the
Peaks that would be hardest to escape
scale now most people believe that it
has not scaled those Peaks yet but what
new emergent capabilities might come
with GT5 or 4.2 I know many people might
comment that it doesn't matter if we
pause or slow down because China would
develop AGI anyway but the author makes
this point he says that it is unlikely
that the Chinese Communist party will
allow a Chinese company to build an AGI
that could become more powerful than
their leader or cause societal
instability he goes on that U.S
sanctions on Advanced semiconductors in
particular the next gen Nvidia hardware
needed to train the largest AI systems
mean that China is likely not in a
position to race ahead of Deep Mind or
open Ai and the center for Humane
technology put it like this in their
talk on the AI dilemma actually right
now the Chinese government considers
these large language models actually
unsafe because they can't control them
they don't shift them publicly to their
to their own population slowing down the
public release of AI capabilities would
actually slow down Chinese advances to
China is often fast following what the
US has done and so it's actually the
open source models that help China
advance and then lastly is that the real
the recent U.S export controls have also
been really good at slowing down China's
progress on Advanced Ai and that's a
different lever to sort of keep the
asymmetry going instead the author
proposes this the island idea in this
scenario the experts trying to build
what he calls god-like AGI systems do so
in a single high secure facility these
would be government-run AI systems with
private companies on the outside and
this little Bridge from the middle and
he says once an AI system is proven to
be safe it transitions out and is
commercialized there might be a few
problems with this idea which he is not
the first to propose I'm going to let
Rob Miles who has a fantastic YouTube
channel by the way point out some of the
problems with putting a super
intelligent AGI in a box so this is kind
of like the idea of oh can we just some
books here right yeah I was like I mean
constraining an AI necessarily means
outwitting it and so constraining a
super intelligence means that witting a
super intelligence which kind of just
sort of by definition is not a winning
strategy you can't rely on outwarding
your super intelligence also it only has
to get out once that's the other thing
if you have a super intelligence and
you've sort of put it in a box so it
can't do anything that's cool maybe we
could even build a box that could
successfully contain it but now what we
may as well just have a box right an AI
properly properly contained may as well
just be a rock right it doesn't do
anything if you have your AI you want it
to do something meaningful
so now you have a problem of you've got
something you don't know has benevolent
you don't know that what it wants is
what you want
and you then need to you presumably have
some sort of gatekeeper who it tries to
says I'd like to do this and you have to
decide is that something we want it to
be doing how the hell are we supposed to
know I also have my own questions about
this idea first I think it's almost
inevitable that future models like GT5
will be trained on data that includes
conversations about GPT models therefore
either consciously or unconsciously and
it might not matter these future
language models might deduce that they
are language models and not having
access to the internet these super
intelligent models might realize that
they are being trained in a secure
facility again if they are super
intelligent it's not a big stretch to
think that they might realize that and
so my question is wouldn't they
therefore be incentivized to be
deceptive about their abilities
realizing that whatever terminal goal
they may have would be better achieved
outside the facility that doesn't have
to be super Sinister but it is super
smart so shouldn't we expect it and so
sadly I think the author has a point
when he says it will likely take a major
misuse event or catastrophe to wake up
the public and governments he concludes
with this warning at some point someone
will figure out how to cut us out of a
loop creating a Godlike AI capable of
infinite self-improvement by then it may
be too late but he does have a call to
action he says I believe now is the time
the leader of a major lab who plays a
Statesman role and guides us publicly to
a safer path will be much more respected
as a world figure than the one who takes
us to the brink as always thank you so
much for watching to the end and let me
know what you think in the comments